hi Chris Chris Gethard is coming in
what's that bud not much how are you I'm
not even nervous about this interview
because we know Chris and also now we
know what we can ask him okay well I
mean did you just hear Chris what is the
best piece of advice you ever received
give yourself no other option in the
book you draw a distinction between
questions you draw a distinction between
not losing and winning can you elaborate
no no these are very fair what are some
examples they're good questions what are
some examples from your career of how
you have successfully embraced your
personal brand of weird oh I wouldn't
know because I've got my own personal
brand of weird but I just can't figure
out how to successfully implement it
into my career Chris Chris's book is
called lose well is it out today or
tomorrow it was out last Oh last Tuesday
okay great good for you but I wish that
event one of the questions on it I know
I'm promoting it that is I need to tell
these people that I took a question I
had a couple of really good ones here
but they got a research there and what
we're getting into a little like which
show are we sending questions to yeah
like these are people I've known for a
long time who also enjoy busting balls
what are we doing there's what is the
mantra funny plus mean to you what is
funny plus me it's the thing I say in
there that when you get good at what you
do you got to try to add a little more
to that like you don't want to just
match where the bars might say you want
to raise it can we really do you do you
know when you go into an interview and
they're reading like yeah
we're I think I've done the same 30
question interview a hundred times why I
can't even imagine why a person who
hosts a radio show would be like oh cool
they did my work this is these are fair
this is one I was a probably a sailor
loaded gun you found a good one I did
yeah I was because I was very curious
about this how can you tell when our
dreams are worth the sacrifice and hard
work that it will take to achieve a
really good question these guys this is
from the people on Harper one lose well
it's a one-sheet by the way chris is
doing book signings we should plug these
of course you can you can ask him all
these questions yourself at the book
signing
yes well the 17th is done the 18th is
done the 20th is done what is today's
date 29th ok the 22nd is done the 25th
is done the 6th is done ok there's one
left which is in Washington DC will be
Monday November the 12th at 7 p.m. it's
at politics and prose which is in
district square and you really should go
and support the book book signings
report on yes they help you on the
bestseller list yes they sell books and
you have to meet Chris say hello and get
your book signed see you right now
stunning insightful question I want to
know about your personal brand of weird
you know I would love to know I mean one
of those famous you know I always tell
you after the show I love when you get
into those Jim Norton questions yeah you
go through the kind of that kind of fake
exterior and you really hit hard you you
I mean you do caution readers that the
world is full of dusty punters oh it's
dusty hunters and he was my first
manager and he was one of these managers
that we've all run into which is like he
wasn't a manager Husum guy trying to
sink his claws into a young kid oh yeah
sure yeah and those are pretty funny
stories this these questions made was
that his real name is that uh no that's
a that's a lot yeah shoot the [ __ ] out
of me for sure here's the true truly
dangerous human
who tried to sign me when I was 20 years
old and it was weird man is he still a
manager I think so iGoogle is the real
name every once in a while and you don't
talk to him at all about oh no no he he
once sent me out on a what turned out I
did not know I thought it was an
audition for a commercial and it was a
hand modeling audition have you seen my
hands I have like a skeletal to fall
nine bloggers like nobody wants their
Doritos with that's very funny but he
did he not know that about you or he
just didn't pay attention he just paid
no attention I was like you got to tell
me when it's it's hand modeling geez
don't mention that dude yeah day off of
work should've sent you out for radar
and mash with that handle what happened
here I was born thing with my elbows and
mine either
Oh [ __ ] up skeleton I never would have
noticed that if you didn't so much say
it and the elbow the elbow is val kilmer
has that and there's a picture of him
from heat wear but they said it was he
injured it in a fall but I wonder he was
just born that way nobody noticed I
think it took a ball of me on the elbow
oh yeah I know that sometimes like you
think that people have that is an injury
that can build where it's just like kind
of grows like a sack on your elbow why
do you claim that it's important to
always be terrified when it comes to
reaching goals
oh man that's such a good question I
feel like I feel like this is the worst
possible timing for me because I feel
like we've gotten to know each other
just well enough just on the other side
of the line where I know that this is
okay AG Montreal weighs probably the
line right like Montreal went really
really well so and and we've run into
each other that seller enough times now
sure I really like Chris I think it's
very funny and unique well you're also
getting but you're getting to know a
different side of him through some of
the great questions yeah I thought you
were gonna be the nice one and you're
being the mean one yeah Jim and I gem
and I have been criticized before with
guests that sometimes we don't
understand that the game is not supposed
to be bad cop worse cop bad cop workshop
Bob will you do advisories occasionally
yeah run that red light why should we
choose to break rules that don't make
sense for us how can we be sure to do so
responsibly what does an exam
from your career when you run a red
light and any works I'm the very very
slim chance any of your listeners have
bought the book they're not returning it
but it's funny the way a book publisher
or a person who doesn't you know just
the way somebody in the business will
phrase things yeah but you also know
that those questions are absolutely
asked every radio phone or the
journaling all this those are all for
the small market radio stations yeah
that you go phoner to Foner and they
just sit there they read the questions
you give the same answer and somehow
everybody just kind of feels like okay
we did it well it is it is also a thing
that's been a little bit of a
back-and-forth between me and the
publisher which is that they are
self-help company and it is I guess in
some sense a self-help book it's a very
pessimistic one where I aim to be funny
sure and I've told them comedy has to
come first it has to I don't I'm not
interested in writing something that's
not funny at its core and I think maybe
they're people are used to working on
the different type of book that doesn't
have that caveat attached yeah but it's
important though when you're a comic the
first thing you have to serve is being
funny and then if it helps you great or
if it's informative great but it's got
to be funny first years your comedian
yeah they saw my HBO special about the
depression stuff and they said we really
want to work with you we think you have
a way of connecting with people and I
said this is a weird challenge to do
something with a self-help company but
I'll go for it why not it's a good deal
it was a good opportunity and I showed
some belief in me and now I got to sit
here and eat [ __ ] during this they did
send a bunch of questions though which
was very funny we got them this morning
boy if it makes you feel any better I
Jim wrote his initials on his microphone
earlier that's why somebody point that
looks like us why'd you do that was that
some OCD I used this mic I don't like
other people using my mic I just want I
don't to breathe in somebody else's
scent and I also don't want somebody
sick anybody so I've been using the old
thing I just realized I don't how do I
know it's mine his name is already on is
this with all microphones no would you
like to stand up as well no no just hear
that guy talk for three hours a day that
is one of the worst things though in
some other comic with like a wet hacking
cough goes like take the night off worst
and your smell your smell of mic it's
[ __ ] horrible girl boom chunk of food
in
it's [ __ ] disgusting a stay mike is
that's why guys use like it the one to
wrap around once for themselves those
little teeny ones because Mike's are
[ __ ] gross I've had it I'm very
physically uncoordinated to where I'll
have it where sometimes I get excited
and like hit my lip oh yeah
Michael touch my lip that I'm sick
comments it put the mic in their mouth
I've seen that we we know the things
comics do and you'd think to like Mike's
aren't that expensive like for a comedy
club to replace a mic every month would
not be that big of a deal but they're
not going to no no it's not gonna happen
no way no I don't like fat Mike's I'm
such a weirdo
I mean Fat Mike I like a thin corded
microphone I don't like a microphone
that's cordless right over here like Bob
Barker and no not-not-not never [ __ ]
you know not a wave microphone just a
regular like Comedy Cellar
you don't like that big cordless 6:01 I
[ __ ] hello I know you're talking about
they're not comfortable they don't feel
natural someone told me the quote
someone said that there's a thing real
comics use corded mics is that a thing
I've never heard that quote but whoever
gave it is probably an ass probably just
an older person that would like they
didn't have cordless microphone yeah you
had to dance over it make it party a
routine shut up
prowl the stage like a panther in that
case isn't it Norton yeah this time I
can't untangle it I'm a clumsy [ __ ] that
is the worst when you walk on stage and
you try to lower the mic stand you can't
lower it and you're like what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I look like I can't lower the mic
stand or I can't untangle it it's just a
brand professional but have you had the
one see where you can't lower the mic
stand and you force it and then it drops
to like two feet out in every sense of
alpha male like my basic tool I don't
know how to use right the one thing I
have is that I'm the one who has the
microphone and I can't figure that out
right I can see it plus then they also
know you don't fix anything in your
house you don't know how to do anything
on your car you figure out a mic Steen
you can't figure out anything so you
happy with the way things are going just
in a broad sense yeah yeah you're doing
good obviously I'm okay you know
the depression sometimes creeps back in
our TV show just got canceled and that's
okay I I
they gave me the option and I pulled the
plug they were do you want to keep
working on it keep fighting for it I was
like nah I'm done what was it where was
it
truTV okay yeah wasn't it on another
place first
it was on fusion and before that we
spent years on public access okay so we
kind of built it our own way and that
was the thing they wrote the numbers
aren't good we have to change it a lot
and I was like I spent years building
this weird psychopath thing myself I
don't want to change what did they want
to change they wanted it to go from an
hour to a half an hour and I felt like
that was gonna squeeze it too much and I
think there was a real obsession with
like the celebrity involvement with it
that was kind of butting heads with the
ability to just do the comedy the way I
wanted to they wanted more celebrities
yeah one of things to revolve around
that it was just a bit much so I'm doing
good overall but definitely a little
stressed out will you do it somewhere
else no I'm done with it
okay but you could I'm sure I could go
pitch some version of it I'm sure
Netflix everyone says that but why not
dude we got cancelled and then like
three weeks later they put all their
shows on truTV put everything on Netflix
I'm like oh god where that would have
helped us a lot yeah I did find an
audience that was more but the show was
also live right Netflix doesn't do live
it was but they were I mean it still
would have replays yeah they would have
it would have had retain the live yeah
you are you worried financially mean are
you just like a little bit no I'm I'm
actually like you know I'm I'm so I
never anytime I get a gig that pays me
money I never changed my lifestyle and I
just continue to live in Queens with my
wife like put my head down and do the
work so money-wise I'm actually I've got
more of a safety net but future wise
it's like the least of a game plan I've
had in ten years and that's just that's
like actually a pretty exciting thing
can also be nerve-wracking because you
just okay you had that steady thing of
okay I'm doing the show it's like and
you know mean well enough to know it's
like I'm doing the show and then I'm
also writing this book on the side
secretly and then I'm also going out on
the road and doing this and that and
it's like it's just the least balls that
I've had in the air in a while so but
there's probably also something about
like you're in a certain place now where
it doesn't quite fit doing the same
thing that you were doing yeah all those
years ago one writer said because the
idea for the TV show I had it when I was
27 and now I'm 38 and I still loved it
but we did also it was like really
absurdist it was like it was like you
know I was like if you ever saw the
movie UHF it was like trying to do that
for real on live TV so it's like they'd
yell at me sometimes the network would
yell at me and I'd be like why are we
fighting like this is a bit where I get
locked in a cage and have piles of human
hair dropped on me like why am I getting
yell
that about the best way to do that it's
the dumbest idea like right if we do it
or we don't like every time they yell at
me I just feel like I'm 38 years old
like this is already such a stupid thing
like I don't need notes on the best way
to get tossed into a dunk tank well they
would know when I given you dumb network
notes they weren't they weren't even
dumb I'll give them more credit than
that and I do appreciate the opportunity
it was just a lot of them there was no
day where they gave us five hours of
notes before the show it's a live show
it's like an hour-long show how can it
give five hours of notes for a live
improvised show it doesn't make sense
especially something that you just made
up as you went for all those years yes
and now go into this place where there's
other people getting their hands on it
yeah it's like this is not what we did
this what the numbers were bad so they
earned that right yeah I'm also humble
enough to know like if the numbers were
huge I could just go ahead sure I'm not
interested but the numbers were calling
in the wrong direction so they were
trying to help but and then I'd have to
go on live TV with five hours of notes
in my head which is not just not fun
right now when Pete I think people who
are watching like I'd my Aunt Karen one
time watch the show and emailed me the
next day
my aunt from free hold she just goes hey
watch the show last night I hope you're
getting enough sleep like that's what
was coming live TV and out on public
access you don't have to worry about the
numbers as much who gives no you just
put it out there and then you stick it
on YouTube and let it find the people
who are gonna find it and they were so
passionate and it was really cool but it
was kind of growing beyond that it was
time to end it
to wrap it up okay but it's something
you could always do again if you want to
and I'm sure it'll serve me well I'm
sure that I'll tell you how it's gonna
serve you well is that obviously it got
canceled right here we go before the
book came out the look in your eye but
now when you're on the tour saying like
lose Wow all failures or you could be
like hey I'm still losing it has
actually segue nicely and I was writing
the book while the show was failing
positive side of failure and how that
can tie into your career and I was like
this is pretty fitting because I see
where this so really the book is just
you trying to help yourself get through
the fact that you know this show is
ending its me desperately trying to
rationalize where I'm at 100%
it's mostly for me but if the rest do
you like it we've got a hard decision to
finally go no I actually feel like
that's something that I've learned over
and over again is one of the only things
that I have as the artist in situations
it's like my ability to call people's
Bluff and be like yeah no thanks and
walk away
right that's one of the only things we
actually have is that our ability to go
like no [ __ ] off sorry doesn't it suck
when they go alright and they actually
let you walk it's true but when it like
when that happens I'm totally okay with
that you got to be ready to walk like
it's like when you when you walk onto a
used car lot you have to be ready to
walk away for real like if you don't
want to buy it you have to and they have
to know and sometimes that won't ice
them to give you a better deal and other
times I'm going now I just can't do it
either and you have to go yeah but it is
it's it is this weird industry that
we're in where it's like there's there's
dozens of professional middlemen who
haven't really proven themselves in any
way right and the ones who do have an
immense amount of respect for but but
you also sometimes when you're going
through that maze like you don't even
know what the actual message that's
coming from above is cuz it gets
filtered through all these people like I
was in percent this is just your opinion
this isn't even the network's opinion
and meanwhile it's like I'm the one who
has to actually go do it I'm the one in
the trenches I'm the one who has to go
test stuff out and see how it succeeds
see how it bombs I'm the one who has to
go do that so if you're telling me
something that's against all my
instincts I'm just gonna walk away yeah
and they don't know sorry
no they do mean well but a lot of times
they just it's like very rarely do you
get network notes as a purpose of comic
or actor that you go that's a great note
it's rare sometimes there is but you
almost like it's never good and when you
do when someone gives you those notes
excuse me you're like hanging on to that
person for dear life yeah that point
where like oh thank God I found someone
who's smart but I feel like you probably
get the same thing to where people look
at me and they're like oh you're so
weird we want that and it's like no you
don't and I feel like for you that must
happen so many times for people like we
want you're like you'll go dark you'll
get raw we want that and then you get
into the notes process and you're like
oh you never want you never wanted that
you want a little enough to say that
that's what you wanted you're right to
think you were cool enough to want that
but you don't want that or you saw one
moment of it or one bit on it and liked
it but when it comes to you know bits
two three four or five and six you want
it to be kind of the way you see a show
going or the way
and again that's this the way they see a
show it's their network but yeah I know
I've never found anything that fit part
of it to me and and maybe I'm just not
good enough in certain areas to make it
work but then there's been other times
I've gone back and forth with notes in
it's like now that's not what I wanted
to do and it's not what you said you
wanted from me either
yeah so yep it happens are you excited
that this book is in people's hands and
out now and like this I think I was up
until 20 minutes ago then it's questions
I have not
did you check no I have not seen those
before what else did you tack what do
you say to people who when frightened by
the idea of building their dream and
just tell themselves no one will get it
anyway what do you say to those people I
can see where in that question the focus
would be on the comedy not the self-help
sure sure come up to you and said Chris
I'm frightened about the idea of
building my dreams I keep telling myself
no one will get it anyway
what would you say to that person now
also as a comedian I'm at the point
where I know this is the funny things
you do but it is intensely painful and
you're putting little condescend me
you're letting me watch you put little
cousin checkmarks yes the one you asked
no yeah acting the paper my way so I see
how many more are lower two more and
they're good questions are they good
yeah are they as good as the ones that
bananas previously yeah I mean it's hard
to get worse
so does this also give you pause when
you hear these questions being read to
you in this way do any of you now go
back to any of the interviews you've
been doing on this press tour and go oh
no we didn't get the book he was reading
off the sheets so basically they were
making you think you were a bigger hit
they do this for all of us I'm sure when
we do a book and it's probably not a bad
idea to have some possible questions you
could rephrase just so the interview
goes well and you sell the book right
this is like I'm feeling shame in like a
junior high school I'm feeling like I
asked a girl to dance and she rejected
me in front of all my peers like it's
that level of it this is your fault this
is should be shame on the book company
right I mean this isn't you it's not
like you did this this is a this is
funny that they would do this and think
that it's a great idea and you're right
about the
who they're sending it to in the sense
that right of course this is gonna get
sent to every lightweight your friends a
much different really are yeah yeah you
don't send it to people who yeah we're
trying to the same way you lose well you
know a failure is actually a success we
try to hurt our friends what are some
examples in your career it's one of
those things aware if it's if it was
this was sent to me about somebody who I
didn't know it's just some actor I mean
we might ridicule that we might not we
wouldn't probably let him know we would
just ignore it and we've been we've been
sent this ship before I even feel like
three appearances ago you would have
ignored it not now you're a comic I
probably immediately would for stand-ups
are different you know I mean you got
Ricky Gervais swith it when they tried
to send like a bio all we did yeah he
hated it too no you guys are repeating
this pin we sure are
oh you know this is a repeat we were
doing about Ricky this is a staple yeah
it sure is
well yeah we asked him Oh what was some
of the questions I don't know wasn't
questions it was the introduction for
him and it was like his his list of like
the number well yeah he was millions of
that and he was like [ __ ] I did have a
momentary instinct of fleeing I won't
hide your fight-or-flight kicked in yeah
and it went like I knew that I knew that
all those questions gave you every
advantage I mean look you do before you
perform stand up even as other areas of
your career continue to gain traction we
love about performing stand-up comedy
that's a really good from one product to
another right that's just a really
inside commit comedy question what do
you love yeah I've been asked that a
million times I always have my answer
for it what is it the immediacy of the
response we do radio it's great but you
really can't tell stand up you know
immediately if you're great or if you
stink huh I think I think I've heard and
read you say sure and what are gonna say
it's it's a question it's not fodder for
a great joke Jiggs
yeah I don't know you know getting blown
what do you want to tell you right I've
said that too I've never had that what
you never had like comedy groupies no
will you how long him a married four
years I had a couple girls there was a
stretch where I was single and I had a
couple
asked me out and we'd go on dates but I
never had but I've never had the comedy
groupie situation I've had some over the
years not as many as a lot of guys but
I've had a decent amount over you know
28 years but they're few and far between
never hooked up after yeah I have
sometimes they knows something they're
not some are not some are actually just
normal and they want a guy who can make
them laugh or they just like what you do
and they know what you do you know it
really depends on where on how somebody
knows you and how yeah a guy who's been
opening for me hooks up all the time on
the road oh really we do the shows and
then people DM em on Instagram it
happens on who's open if you lookin this
guy named Carmen Christopher he's pretty
good okay a lot of times it's a guy that
will get late anyway like I'm not
necessarily a guy that will get late
anyway so what I would put a beast yeah
I also don't I don't drink that's a big
piece of the puzzle sure to go out have
a drink and get somebody a dream yeah
I'll buy you a drink but I won't you
know I just sit there like a [ __ ]
vulture with club soda so it's kind of
creepy that starts to be feel predatory
right when you're like let me buy you a
drink and then you're like I'll get a
Seltzer for myself and I don't want
somebody too drunk
I mean it just I don't want it just
doesn't it doesn't turn me on because
what turns me on as a woman being dirty
but someone who's too drunk to go
[ __ ] sloppy what he gonna puke like I
don't want to deal with it yeah that
fine line between dirty and sloppy is a
real deal breaker [ __ ] crazy man yeah
like I like somebody's real mentality
like there are girls who are just
[ __ ] dirty and I like that mentality
it turns me on a lot like a woman who is
who understands what makes me turned on
and knows how to utilize that is a sexy
quality someone who's just will drunk
and will do anything it's like you do
this for anybody can I here's something
I've always wanted to ask you are there
are there are there do you find that
you'd be an example from your love
example of one are there people who take
that as a challenge though are there
people come at you who are like I'm
gonna out dirty northie
I don't know I mean um can they they
sure I mean there's weird I'll tell you
one thing that stops me in my tracks you
know a [ __ ] period a girl's period is
a [ __ ] is garlic around the window
for me it's a crucifix well that's
because it represents the wrong type of
genitals that's an excellent point I
hadn't thought of that don't get their
periods and they can't get pregnant yeah
you like that you bet I do
yes but yeah that period is not my thing
look and I wish it was because there's
so many guys that love that but that's
more guys that love it I mean love it
really fetish for a lot of guys I know
they're guys that will put up with it
can stand they're called Ruby showers
those guys that love them
Ruby showers showers that wings right
you're red burning you're red wings yeah
but the fetish in front of my crime
scene sex I know her yeah yeah yeah they
get period on them I guess or Roman
showers is being puked on like I don't
get that one either
Roman Holloway as a very very well-known
not my thing
those are not those were a couple of
things that will stop me in my tracks
but periods more than anything will stop
me I didn't know that I was into eating
ass until someone made me do it they
they made you do that how did she make
you better how excited that kid because
he said she made him do it a whole tone
of voice changed how did she she grabbed
me by the hair and put me where she
wanted me that's amazing so hard because
I'm so glad you said that because Jim
always gets like when somebody says no I
I don't do that haven't done that he
goes like what are you doing doing it's
it's literally it's it's stingy on their
part so now you like doing it you love
it
did she sit on your face to get you to
do it or she grabbed you and put your
been later in her stomach she was on all
fours did she say eat it or to reach
back oh that's so she [ __ ] that's so
sexy how do you figure it out when
that's like a foreign concept you're
like I just don't it's not in my
repertoire she's kind of pointing me in
at the angle away from where I would
think and then I heard her giggling and
I was like oh she's making me do this
and it's like a Power Move
that's so [ __ ] I would have sniffed
it first would you dog what if it wasn't
so fresh at times it's not I mean
there's a line to it where you want it
to be you know good right do I clean Jim
likes a little sweaty yeah I like right
out of the shower Oh
dive in Jake's right after a jog yeah
she's ready hour I'll throw on the
[ __ ] bike in the gym for an hour yeah
go in there and [ __ ] ask this thing
up you [ __ ] goose jim says we can we
can skip that final step at Equinox
there's no reason to stop in the showers
right back to the apartment yeah but I
mean that's that to me see that right
there she made me do like that is like
is so that goes back to [ __ ] when I
was 14 and in the making you do it and
putting just guiding your head that
turns me on some
you like getting treated like a worm
yeah basically yeah yeah just [ __ ]
warmed up get back there and [ __ ] put
your [ __ ] head my ass and hang out
like it's an apple yeah I guess I'm more
of a submissive than that like I can be
dominant too but I like the so I like
that what about when people try to be
dominant but it's just not sexy it's
just like you know you're putting on an
act like it's like anything else I'm
sure I try to shove my dick in that's
not hard it's not sexy either so right
double thumbing it is exactly it [ __ ] my
nails are a little long so I'm [ __ ]
poking my head I know I know I know I
got to keep these nails in mmm a level
you think I'm Jacob yes the worse right
that nothing is a worse source of shame
than that
yeah just doesn't work but you know what
it will it is that an issue for you
Chris cuz Jim has a real issue with that
time I'm not gonna lie it's happen it's
particularly I tell you it's a
particularly embarrassing as you when
your last name spells out the words get
hard right mine does Oh Mike I didn't
realize that come on no really no never
yes Oh my name's spells get hard right
at least I'm sure they didn't make fun
of you like in school for that oh my god
you have no idea
maybe that's what my career is not a con
past the level it's not I didn't realize
that GE th ard was fodder for comedy I
didn't you say it were you haven't
gotten quite to fifth grade humor I'm
the worst you're down around second yeah
that really is humiliating yeah it's bad
it's bad yes my middle name is Paul so
it's C Paul get hard so what are you
doing that happened you can't get it out
yeah well you know now married and
obviously one of the things you get
married to someone for is your good
sexual chemistry so it's much less of an
issue but it would happen back in the
day and it was always embarrassing it
was always embarrassing what do you do
yeah I guess you just go you say it's
not you then you go to pizza what do you
do I blame them you thanks for nothing
Pig this doesn't happen when it's not
you exactly thanks a lot
German have
sex with the rubber pelvis to try to get
himself back to the point where he can
say to normal yeah where do you get
where'd you get that um it's for to a
porn place I ordered one of the male - I
got I haven't used them the weeks though
after talking about in the air it's just
too silly it's just silly we were all
teasing you for it but you're right yeah
I can actual fake vagina yeah yeah so
not not what's why not like a fleshlight
why did you choose I used one too and I
broke it I kept away how do you break up
well if you like the [ __ ] I kept
bucking it and the and the fleshy part
was caving into my dick was hitting the
plastic and I got so mad one night I
took it and I with oil on my hands
smashed it on my floor and shattered it
that's a that's a water that's a high
watermark yeah that's one step below a
belt but I don't want this show yeah
they here they like what the [ __ ] is he
doing always hemming yet we go these
smashing flashlights again I don't want
this show to to be a negative thing for
your sexual health if you need to [ __ ]
severed torso is for a while I don't
want it I don't want us giggling at your
expense I'm back to the nipple play the
sex doll brothels I have yet to just
repulsive to me Toronto and I don't get
it to go [ __ ] a doll and pay for it how
kraut creepy but yeah it's really cuz
you know that I mean they're like comedy
clubs in the sense the comedy clubs
don't switch out mics every time they're
not switching out the dolls every time
there's an issue right women don't
scribble you a [ __ ] woman other
people have [ __ ] her but there's just
something different the body has a
natural way of cleansing itself that a
rubber doll doesn't its disgusting it is
so you react like jerking off a lot and
stuff not a lot but I've got shot a few
Oh No Troy [ __ ] you weren't wrong I mean
I would have to but I want you to be
sexy are you still using your pump yeah
I used it once yesterday occasionally
here and there are you getting your
treatments I haven't gone but I have I
have two more to get and I'm done and I
was just push away I've been going for
these dick wanderings
I'm shocked at the amount of things I
really am I'm uh I just been getting
them wanted with sound waves and it's
just good to repair because I jerked off
for so many years so rough did you go
dry not went dry but it was just like
the sensitivity wasn't what it was and
they're actually pretty helpful the wand
ins yeah yeah yeah there's my favorite
quote the whole time lead to some fetish
no one's kind of probably a lot electric
shock in my day like need a girl to like
hum on why don't you write a self-help
book except just about south helping
your own dick I don't want that I have a
lot of experience with it that can go
wrong and the windings that you have to
put a cream on that numbs you think they
hurt like I mean again they're worth it
but my dicks more sensitive I thought
you have to numb the dick for the one we
like dying and yeah I have the sound of
somewhere let me see if I can find this
sound do you guys talk there's a chance
you picked the wrong audio file down we
all hear something that we do not want
to hear oh yeah yeah when you start
hearing about disastrous stuff like this
does it start to make you feel a little
better about your life yeah that's good
everybody's got something everybody's
got stuff going on do people when you
write a book like this do people go to
the signings and stuff and feel like now
since you're so like you did your
special you've done this book you're so
kind of open about your your mental
stuff do people feel like they can share
with you all of their [ __ ] oh yeah you
have no idea and you don't want to know
every day every day since my special I
get messages online from people who are
in really dark places I've been through
dark stuff and it's uh it's very
beautiful and flattering that they feel
you know some people say I've never
opened up to anyone about this but it's
also it's like there is an element to
which it's like you're making a point to
tell me because I've publicly gone here
and I'm so flattered but also you're
getting it off your chest and it kind of
winds up on me a little bit like I just
get sad I get sad here right and there's
nothing you can do nope zero things I
can do yeah it's very hard and then
sometimes I won't answer people because
I can't answer all those things and then
people get get matted or take it as if
like oh the guy who
it's about this won't talk about it with
me and it's like I can't talk to
thousands of people about depression
I'll jump off a [ __ ] bridge right
right I try to say I've gotten like
people who write they say man I want to
commit suicide I get that and if I see
that I'll answer it sometimes I don't
say I don't check all my messages all
the time and I get a lot of email but
you always want to give somebody a
little encouragement but when it's a lot
of people and it's like like I don't
know what's going on in your life do you
drink you do drugs you a PTSD or you
just may feel like I don't know what the
[ __ ] you know I don't know what's going
on I'm not qualified my shrink my shrink
actually had to step in and say like you
can't you can't even try you have to
ignore all this stuff you're not trained
to do this or qualified to do it yeah
all right give advice walk in tell that
[ __ ]
I give specific advice and guarantee
results probably just refer them to it
therapist anything yeah yeah I found the
sound you did okay this is the sound
that repairs so if everybody can put
their dicks to the radio right now
you're actually gonna repair the tissue
well do you see you can't see my dick do
you see what she's holding like do you
see that there's a glove and someone's
like a [ __ ] a welding gun what the
[ __ ] is that you can hear Lee oh my God
my dick feels better already
it's like a jacket it certainly is what
happens she just runs it over your dick
and it shoots in sound waves and they do
mic they give you micro tears little way
underneath the surface and what happens
is when you're when you're you're you
pump your dick or whatever it forces
blood into your dick to repair them and
you get new vessels and stuff like that
and it's just better for it makes your
dick healthier you're numb your dick is
numb while that happens yeah I mean not
totally numb you can feel it do you get
hard from no she told me some guys have
but I can't nothing that and I've gotten
the PRP shots twice which is when they
pull blood out of your arm and they do
something with the blood and they it's
platelet rich blood and then they inject
it into your dick the first time that
happened I almost threw up and fainted
in the second time they had to numb me
with other shots in like like in my
pubis and then they did the five shots
they were they hurt and if it's all
covered by ensuring you're paying out of
pocket for all this yeah why not the
insurance doesn't care about my dick
how did you even find on-camera
treatment I had I did a pilot for show
Danny Daniels a porn star she had this
dinner with Danny it was just fun thing
where it's like they're like you and a
few porn stars eat dinner so I sounds
fun
it was great that was with her Alexis
Texas Akira and and Phoenix Marie and I
think that and Danny and during the
thing Phoenix Marie does this Gaines
wave it's called and she told me about
it she talked about it yeah where they
was AB waves into your dick and supposed
to help with your erection so I talked
to her after and she's like no it's the
legit thing I've gone for training and
you really do this so I looked it up in
New York I talked to a doctor friend he
goes yeah there's good research on it
it's like even if it doesn't help your
erection it's just it's better for your
dick it's just healthier for your dick
so I wasn't jerking you off so I went
and when I was in Vegas I actually went
and saw her for a session too so I had
this [ __ ] sexy porn star handling my
dick I was all numbed up and she told me
like yeah even I said she was
complimenting my penis oh my god
completely unsexual though I got nothing
but you get to think about that
afterwards I did yep she might have just
been being polite I don't know that's
why beat yourself up like that and that
seems pretty specific like yeah I would
too yeah but she had gloves on but did
she or no I don't know it doesn't change
her opinion she's very nice you just
used a presence of gloves as a way to
say like ah she doesn't really know my
dick yeah when you have loves on every
dick is a nice day that's a good point
yeah she was but you but she does it and
it's legit and she knew what she was
doing I trusted her you know cause she
again she's uh she showed me the class
that she goes to and like what they do
to train you and it's really intense
training you have to go through to get
certified to do this and I would say I
was in a medical facility it's amazing
yeah and so I suggested I do it here in
New York Wow yeah man
did you watch you said wrestling before
did you watch evolution last night the
old women's pay-per-view no Rhonda did
very very very well it's amazing how
quickly Rhonda is taking to Ronda Rousey
is taking a pro wrestling well she's a
great athlete and she loved it anyway so
it does it you know I studied for almost
well now this moment she took the
showmanship side of it right yeah yeah
like she's becoming an entertainer I I
guess she's done movies before but it's
pretty amazing to watch and did the girl
the new girl from Japan debut last night
uh was that yeah from a young classic
age yep that's awesome
hey yo he was great too it's a they do
in all women's tournament Oh in the
network and they did yeah but they did
their first all women's pay-per-view
okay Milan last night and it was really
it was a good show you see does that
true they're pushing a lot of a female
fighters because again they are good
fighters yeah and I think they also want
that market and and it will also get
young women to maybe more interested in
instead of just watching guys fight
they're actually watching you know
something that they feel more connected
to my email fights headline now oh yeah
yeah
cyborg Amanda newness is the co-main
event I think it I think it the garden
Cormier Lewis I believe that that's the
Cohen people are rumour in about denied
the words are it's not it's uh in Vegas
at the end of the Earth's are coming
people are throwing rumors around about
WWE trying to bring in cyborg you know
she has more fights in UFC and she's
still such a [ __ ] but she could come
into WWE to do something come back to
UFC type of thing I guess she could yeah
I'm rock did yeah and yeah Ronnie never
came back but yeah there's the thing
they talked about Conor doing it but he
won't but I think eventually he will he
will event be too much right right I
think Conor once he's kind of finished
in UFC that's when he'll take it over
into WWE world I bet if he loses two
more fights yes it starts fine deal
six fight deal and I he'll pick the next
fight
carefully I mean he lost the khabib he's
not gonna get the rematch immediately so
he might fight one more fight maybe he
does Nate Diaz atop of Anderson Silva
which I really don't need to see it
[ __ ] I wanna see him fight yeah but
you know it you know night of you'd be
like I would watch this yeah yeah
that's at W you got Ronda probably I
mean she want to fight anymore cuz she
was losing yeah then Amanda loss was
terrible yeah you're a debbie weg she
could be the champion forever you know
yeah I think yeah I think that the
co-main in Vegas Jon Jones against
Gustafson which I'm happy to see Jones
fighting again I am yes I feel like it's
been it's such a series of like it's not
just the steroid stuff it's like
crashing the car and running away it's
that stuff where it's like it's hard to
root for the guy at this point it's fun
to watch him a fight though I wouldn't
say that I run for undoubtedly yeah and
he's undefeated I mean the day that one
loss was a [ __ ] technicality [ __ ]
him you know twelve o'clock elbow I mean
come on that was a nonsense law so he's
technically undefeated do you think he
was just like do you think he's a
pathological liar do you think you
because he came in here and he did his
whole spiel
he has to lie here and if two weeks
later he's busted for but I mean he went
over the top to talk about how not on
steroids I almost don't think he did
this one on purpose
because the stuff they found wouldn't
have worked immediately it's a
cumulative effect it would have done
nothing for him and it was like the day
of it was like you know in the fight day
test it would have been absolutely
stupid for him to do it knowing that
they test for [ __ ] so no I don't think
he lied about this I don't think he did
it on purpose didn't you lied about the
last one I don't know I mean again they
found I guess they found where the
tainted supplement was but I don't see
how much bad lavas bad luck could happen
to one person what's happened they found
it in Brazil they found it was a
facility that was tainted so a couple of
guys Junior dos Santos and a couple of
other guys who had tested positive they
were they were exonerated not John Jones
oh no they might have yeah but these
multiple times for him I think he
probably takes a lot of supplements too
so the more supplements you taking the
more things you take the more risk
you're at just stop taking them yeah
yeah you talked to I know you think
you'd learn that yeah